92 of abortions are
committed for no reason and every girl
and honestly it matches with what i've
seen i know a couple people that have
had abortions every one of them was
irresponsible yeah they were not any
contraception none that's crazy like and
this is this is what i've seen in in
real life like i don't know a single
person that was actually precautious and
got an abortion it was literally just
them being a response i feel like people
wouldn't well i like the people i know
if we're going to talk about personal
experiences and people we know yeah
people i know wouldn't have an abortion
for no reason because it's such an
uncomfortable process
it's not something you want to do
essentially yeah but there are some
girls who would just it's like a choice
you have to make so i'm saying like a
lot of people are like i'm pro-choice
but i don't think it's like a
comfortable choice i don't think it's
like i'm going to enjoy this right but
that's what i'm saying
but some girls who actually just
don't care
do you know what i mean like i think
that's the exception
i don't think that's the thing
every girl like i know that's had well i
know i know girls that have had like
multiple and they just kept doing the
same thing i think if you have multiple
abortions you can actually die from that
i think it does a woman i think she was
from i'm not i'm not gonna say but i
think that goes into the point of like
you don't really care like what you're
doing when it comes to that aspect i'm
like okay cool if you're doing this
repeatedly now
i like pro choice yeah everything like
that but like
it does come to a point where you're
being okay why do you like why why do
you keep doing this
we don't care about like what someone
else does the thing is i have a friend
like
in the in the sense of um
[Music]
like okay so me personally i am
pro-choice pro-life for myself but i
don't care what someone else does but as
you are all
pro-life or pro-choice sorry you're
pro-choice so you're like laissez-faire
like you know do what you want
but if you're saying do you want why do
you care if someone is habitually doing
it because at like i personally i
couldn't care like if you want to keep
doing that that's you because again that
is a traumatic experience and especially
in america like more times than not
you're paying for that yourself like
it's 500 i don't care because it comes
to a point where it's going to have an
effect on you yeah but i think from the
beginning i
any any abortion it doesn't matter if
it's by choice or not like say medical
reasons or like you deciding that it's
not in your best interest or whatever
the case either way is going to be a
traumatic experience and no yes it is
how yes it tells me how it's going to be
no but no that's going to be immensely
like very girls girls cat hair
that's what some say and then if you're
gonna talk about the physical aspects of
it abortion is perfectly safe so i
didn't say it wasn't safe i just said
that it was traumatic but sometimes it's
not no it's not traumatic on the body
so it has no effect on your body it has
no effect i'm not saying it doesn't have
an effect you say it's traumatic
traumatic is up here it's not there
unless you don't care about it
physically
it's as safe as a penicillin shot
correct that's what it says
when i'm saying some people some women
actually take a mental and emotional
attachment to the abortion that's when
it's traumatic there's some girls out
there who just don't care and will have
an abortion not saying that they can't
have it but we'll have an abortion and
continue to do that to the point where
i'm like okay
how actually how are you as how are you
like are you okay like
if you keep doing this and you think
it's like you keep getting pregnant
having an abortion getting pregnant
having an abortion getting pregnant
having an abortion i don't even know how
many times people have done it
individually but i'm just saying like it
comes down to the health of the mother
when it when it it's gonna have an
effect of you on you whether or not you
let it after multiple times can i just
make a point real quick um i've had so
in the in that situation i'll agree with
you only because i have one friend
female friend right who's had um
i think about
i don't want to say like about five
abortions more or less so
with
twice
no sorry three times with the same guy
um and then twice with two others but
like in like a safe relationship they've
been dating for like a couple years
right
so
obviously at first i was like um like
you know when she sprung it on me like
the first couple times it was fine but
then after a while i'll i will agree
with you then it was kind of like after
like the fourth and final like bro like
what the [ __ ] are you doing it's kind of
an adaptive behavior like but the thing
is if you're looking at it from uh for
if you're looking it from from the first
guy's time right like because obviously
if you're looking from a guy's as like
obviously
in in a sense of like let's say they did
it they had the girl gets pregnant and
she has an abortion right but let's say
if you're looking from a guy's
perspective right the guy wants to keep
her because the guy because her
boyfriend wanted to keep the baby but
all three times that he had it that she
she had a shadow and a [ __ ] in that
sense would you say that abortion's
wrong from like also it's at the end of
the day is the girl's choice to make get
abortion because it's her body and
whatever a lot but like if she might not
want to keep and he had a discussion
right but he wants to do you think that
that would like affect them yeah like
do you think the guy has like at the end
of the day does the guy have a say in it
uh as much as like i said the end of the
day she they give my talk about it agree
to it but then she does it anyways you
know because at the end of the day all
she needs to go to do to the clinic and
be like oh i like an abortion please
yeah nowadays okay cool they do i mean
they say at the end of the day
because he has an emotional there's an
emotional like element that he's going
to play exactly because that's
potentially your potential
child to be if you know what i'm talking
about to me to me you can voice an
opinion in the same way about like
uh i raise the point of things like body
hair okay obviously these are vastly
different issues okay
miles apart but um but you can have an
opinion
you can express a preference
doesn't mean i have to listen to it and
i probably like like that's good yeah to
me it's like if you if if a guy if say
if the same guy has no say in this
that's what i'm hearing
yeah after the first abortion and the
second abortion you're like okay she
doesn't value my opinion but even
but then why do you keep nutting in
someone that you know like if you know
like why do you keep doing that is it
all roots back in knowing going into
everything that you do with intention if
you know one that you can be pregnant by
doing this and two if if you're
habitually like if i keep getting an
abortion and we're together and you want
the baby obviously go one stop having
sex with me and two have sex with
someone that wants to have a baby don't
just be having sex with anyone i mean
in their defense they were together for
like seven
living
years
in this in in this instance and it
sounds like the guy was you have a baby
like multiple abortions anyway do you
guys since men have no say and if a
woman gets an abortion do you think and
so since sorry let me phrase this better
since men men have no say in if a woman
gets an abortion right would you guys
agree that that's fair
yeah it is the fairest thing half the
final they don't yeah right so at the
end of the day if a man has no i want
this kid like i want you to carry this
kid and she says
she has the choice yeah yeah like she
gets the i just wanna i'm gonna lead
into something so just yes or no okay
yeah yeah oh no they they
they don't have a say and especially
because if if okay if you if you want to
have this kit great you can carry it
right okay so this is so then concave
that's fine
okay so we're on the same page